well Joe Biden lounges at the beach
Kamala Harris gets to pretend to be
president
looking at her meeting here with the
foreign leader I think that's the
Mongolian leader not the Mongolians
tomorrow she heads to Wisconsin and
Friday she'll try to spend the monthly
jobs report seems like she's getting
pretty comfortable the VP getting her
big wish after her team has been
complaining of her quote being left out
of the spotlight this includes a
softball interview with ABC news but
even that was too much for Kamala to
handle watch there were reports that say
that you have the lowest approval rating
of any vice president I'm curious how
much of a role if any that you feel race
and gender play in that well there are
polls that also say I have great
approval ratings I think the point that
has to be made is that there are
attempts to create distractions away
from the accomplishments of our
Administration
okay so we'd like to see those poll
numbers any day because everyone we've
seen shows voters think Harris is doing
a historically bad job
but there's some good news for Kamala if
you can call it that voters are more
enthusiastic for her to be the 2024
nominee than her boss Joe Biden uh Dana
take it away well this is Kamala reboot
224 if you're keeping count and I can
understand why they're trying to give
her a little bit more publicity but I
think she has a brand new team again
right did that make sense look and the
Mongolians they're those are good
Freedom Fighters and we need them on our
side so thank you Mongolians for coming
to visit I love that barbecue
those are their faces actually indeed
[Music]
um
look she one of the things she said is
that uh she has this quote talking about
busty migrants is Cinema and grand
gestures and political games okay well
one a lot of politicians do that you
host events so that you can do that but
on busting migrants like she was
supposed to be in charge of immigration
and she's greyhounds
that is a very good one I
um think this that she's going to be
elevated by both sides okay because the
Republicans want people to know that if
you elect Joe Biden and he's 80 and not
in good health then the likelihood of
her becoming president during the next
four years is higher than you would want
if you're a republican but the Democrats
also need to elevate her because she's
dragging down Joe Biden's numbers and
they need her and especially because
they're concerned about the black vote
not turning out they need her to have a
more visible presence on the campaign
Trail so you'll see more of her which
will be great for the five that will be
great Greg when you see that poll where
people are excited for a Kamala
nomination that a Biden nomination is
that kind of like people excited if they
see a car wreck maybe like the spectacle
of it how dare you insult a car wreck
they have feelings too do you know that
but I feel like the bull Biden family is
trolling comology you see that rumor in
the post uh
it's great it's it's uh Joe Biden's
sister Otherwise Known big gal uh
you know that's upsetting Kamala Harris
when the president's sister is like you
don't be a good president Meghan Markle
I mean that's just jamming it in am I
feeling the only way that Kamala sticks
around is as Gavin newsom's running mate
and then you're gonna get two people
from California representing the
Democrats I mean that's the worst state
in the Union that's like choosing two
members of the view to represent America
in the Miss Universe Pageant it's not a
good choice I'm gonna blow your minds
this this election right now isn't
against uh the the candidates you think
the Democrats don't have any it's not
going to be Joe Biden I I'm I'm gonna
say Joe Biden's not going to be there so
Trump far far and away is the uh is the
candidate for the Republican party what
do you have over there what do you have
over there you have a machine right it's
a political machine so it's Trump versus
the machine and he's raging against this
machine right it's a political Beast
it's corrupt and it punishes those who
won't obey that's the real race him
versus this monolith that is trying to
destroy the average American how do you
like that for Man versus machine do you
like it Katie not if the machine is
smarter because that's terrifying and
throw water on it that's true that's
like it's like the Wicked Witch of the
West yeah just pour some water on it and
it fries
um they put her out here there so many
times and she tries so hard and it's
like she just can't do it and the
question that she constantly gets from
reporters is isn't this because America
is racist and sexist and she actually
could do herself a big favor by saying
no no actually I'm in this position
because I'm a qualified woman who has
something to offer Americans whether
it's my experience in California or my
desire to solve these problems that
she's not solving but she could actually
turn that question over and help herself
with that but this is is the reason why
Nikki Haley says that they're running
against Kamal Harris they're not running
against Joe Biden and I would watch
Gavin Newsom because I wouldn't be put
it behind him or past him that he
wouldn't start going after Kamala Harris
but she thinks that she's entitled to
this position even though she couldn't
get a single vote in the Democratic
primary when she ran for president and
Gavin Newsom wants it and he's not going
to let her just take it especially since
her approval ratings are so low and
she's not very good at the job so are we
dreaming are these things never going to
happen is it going to be Biden or is it
going to be a knife fight between Kamala
and Gavin Newsom
I have no reason to think that it is hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else